the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
everyone today we are going to look at
dynamic programming again so I think I
have mentioned several times so you
should all know it by heart now the
dynamic programming its main idea is
divided a problem into subproblems and
we use the results of the problems
you've already solved right and of
course in 604 6 we always care about
runtime so those are the two are our big
themes for dynamic programming now let's
start with a warm up example it's really
simple let's say we have a grid there's
a robot
from say coordinate 1 1 and it wants to
go to coordinate MN so at every step it
can only either take a step up or take a
step on the right so how many distinct
paths are there for the robot to take
is the question clear so we have a robot
at coordinate 1 1 it wants to go to
coordinate MN and it every step it can
either take a step up or take a step to
the right how many distinct paths are
there that can take the robot to its
destination any ideas how to solve that
but problems as
at some point yeah
yeah yeah does that one get that so it's
very simple I know I have only one way
to get to this points why I need to go
all the way right and only one way to
get to these points I need to go all the
way up so for all the intermediate nodes
my number of choices are discarding just
a number of distinct paths I can come
from my left plus the number of distinct
paths I can come from bottom and then I
keep going for every node I'll just take
a sum between like the two numbers on my
left and on my bottom and go from there
okay
it's got clear
so this example is very simple but it
does illustrate the point of dynamic
programming very well as you are use of
subproblems and ask how many distinct
paths can I come here and you reuse the
result of for example this subproblem
because you are using it to compute this
number and that number if you don't do
that if you don't memorize and reuse the
results and while your runtime will be
worse so what's the runtime of that
let's pick up
it's just an M times n right why because
I have this many unique subproblems one
at each point and and I'm just taking a
sum of two numbers at each subproblem so
it takes me constant time to solve to
merge the results from my cell problems
to get my problem so to analyze run time
usually we ask a question how many
unique problems do I have and what's the
amount of merge work I have to do at
every step that's the toy example
let's look at some more complicated
examples our first one is called make
change as its name suggests we have a
bunch of coins as one as to all the way
to say SM so each coin has some values
like 1 cent 5 cent 10 cent and then
we're going to make it make change for a
total of incense and ask what's the
minimum number of coins
do I need to make a change event and
cents
so to guarantee that we can always make
this change will set as one to be 1
otherwise there is a chance that if the
problem is solvable any ideas
oh it's the problem clear go ahead
what least these numbers they are input
they are also inputs it could be one
seven five seven ten cents or three
cents seven cents though the smallest
one is always one okay I need to find a
combination of them for each of them I
have infinite number of them so I can
find two of these three of those five of
that two such that their sum is n is the
problem tree okay any ideas how to stop
that
let's just use naive or very
straightforward algorithms
god
okay great yeah let's just do exhaustive
search let's pick si if I pick this coin
then my sub problem becomes n minus the
coin value right and of course I use the
one coin right that's a tie so then I
take a mean of this for all the ice and
that's the solution so far so good
okay so what's the runtime of this
algorithm
it's not immediately obvious then we ask
how many unique subproblems are there
and how much work do I have to do to go
from my subproblems to my original
problem so how many subproblems are
there
so to be clear for this one we have to
call this recursive core again right and
- si probably - SJ
and if you cannot compute how many
subproblems are there let's just give a
bound
any ideas
jump right
I
yeah correct so this may not be a very
tight bound but we know we cannot have
more than this number of subproblems
right actually I don't need to even put
the order there I know we can have no
more than n subproblems they'll just
make change of N and minus 1 and minus 2
all the way to them to make change 1 and
actually this bound is pretty tight
because we set our smallest coins 1 so
we will make a recursive call to make
change n minus 1 right if I pick the one
coin a one-cent coin first and then from
there I will pick a 1 cent coin again
that gives me a subproblem but minus 2
so indeed I will encounter all the n
subproblems right ok so having realized
that how much work do I have to do to go
from here to there
Yeah right right because well I'm taking
a mean of how many terms M terms so
that's all run time
any questions so far
okay if not let me take a digression so
make change this problem if you think
about it it's very similar to knapsack
as anyone not proud of this problem
knapsack means you have a bunch of items
you want to pack these into a bag and
the bag has a certain size and you want
to sew each item has a certain value and
you want to pack the items that have the
largest combined value into your bag so
why is it why are they similar because
if so in some sense n is our size we
want to pick a bunch of coins to make
the size N and each coin here actually
has a negative value because we want to
pick the minimum of it if you do that
then this problem is exactly knapsack
and knapsack is np-complete that means
we don't know a polynomial solution to
it yet however we just found one
right this our input is and stuff and
then our solution is polynomial 2m and
polynomial to the N right if this is
true then I have found a polynomial
solution to one NP problem so P equals
NP so we should all be getting Turing
Award for that so clearly something is
wrong
no but there's nothing there's no
problem with this solution right this
covers all the cases and our analysis is
definitely correct
so yeah does anyone get what I'm asking
so what's the contradiction here
we'll probably discuss this later in
later lectures when we get to complexity
or reduction so but to give a short
answer the problem is that when we say
the input is n its size is not n so I
only need log in this to represent this
input right make sense
therefore for log in length input my
runtime is n that means my runtime is
exponential it's not polynomial okay now
that's end of the digression
okay now let's look at another example
this one is called rectangular blocks so
in this problem we have a bunch of
blocks say 1 2 all the way to N and each
each of them has a length width and
height so it's a three dimensional block
so I want to put blocks stack them on
top of each other to get a maximum
height but in order for J could be put
on top of them
I require the length of J could be
smaller than length of I and width of J
is also smaller than with a pie so
visually I just meant so this is a block
I can put another block on there right
they are smaller in width and length but
I cannot put this guy on top of it
because one of them one of its dimension
is larger than the underlying block and
to make things simple ah that's not
allowed rotating so okay I can rotate it
now it's still doesn't fit but you see
the complication sorry that you allow
rotate then there's more possibility so
L and length and width are so one of
them is north/south the other is
east/west you cannot change that
okay is the problem clear we want to
stack one on one on top of each other to
look at the maximum height
any ideas again let's start from simple
algorithm say let's just try everything
out
okay go ahead
funny
you're going too fast let's write the
algorithm first so I want to solve my
rectangle block problem say from 1 to N
what are my subproblems
okay that's true as one block
so I get his height and then I have a
sub problem what is the sub problem and
then I'll take a max Y right so the
difficulty here is ah this sub problem
so Andrew right so Andrew said it's just
everything except I is that a case go
ahead
right you get that yeah not only with we
have to exclude I we also we also have
to exclude everything longer or wider
than I so that's actually a messy
problem so let me define now this uh
broad problem to be a compatible set of
Li and Omega s sorry WI and let me
define that to be the set of blocks
where the length is smaller than the
required length and therewith sorry it's
also smaller than the required width so
this should remind you of the weighted
interval scheduling problem where we
define a competitive compatible set once
we have chosen some block
question Optum up maximize h we want to
get as high as possible I choose a block
I get its height and then I find out the
competitive remaining blocks and I want
to stack them on top of it
okay everyone agrees this problem this
solution is correct okay then let's
analyze this runtime
so how do we analyze run time
what's the first question I always ask
yeah I not sure who said that but how
many subproblems do we have
at most an
can you explain why is that case it's
just a gas and if the compatibles
nothing in the canal and will not be in
the compatible
okay that's very tricky I didn't get
that can say I can like you to start
with and then everything that's in the
compatible set and won't be in the
comparison
okay I think I got what you said so if
we think there are only n sub problems
what are they they have to be compatible
set L 1 w 1 then our 2 W 2 right these
artists and unique subproblems you are
thinking of thinking about right now is
there any chance that I will get a
compatible set like something like L 3
but W 5 right if I ever have this sub
problem then well my number of
subproblems are kind of exploding
yeah I see many of you are saying no why
not because if we have subproblems say
compatible set of Li and WI and if we go
from here and choose a next item choose
the next block say T it's guaranteed
that T has aa is shorter and narrower
right that means our new subproblem or
new compatible set becomes our new
subproblem need to be compatible with T
instead of I right so the only
subproblems I can get are these ones
like I cannot I cannot have one of these
okay so subproblems are the number of
subproblems are n and how much work do I
have to do
at each level
and
yeah yeah because I'm just taking the
max right and there are n potential
choices inside my max so runtime and
square
okay we're not fully done because there
is an extra step when we are trying to
do this we have to figure out what each
of these are right because once I go
into into this sub-problem I need to
take a max on all the blocks that's in
this set right I have to know what
blocks are in that set is the heart
so how would you do that
okay so I check all of them
that's over then I get I'm pretty sure
you just been scanning
scan the entire thing and pick out the
compatible ones right but that's for
this sub problem you have to do it for
everyone
oh there may be a better way so I think
the previous tier is telling me there is
a better way to do that so in order to
find the entire compatible self he
claims you can do it in and login but I
haven't checked that so I'm not sure
this is a folklore legend here yeah
we'll double-check that offline but
assuming if I if I don't have this then
figure out all these sub problems we'll
also take n square right then my total
runtime is n square plus n square and
still n square
I started the ammonia solution
keeping a sort of
yeah I think it should be something
along those line but yeah I haven't
figure out whether you sort by length or
you by width or you can only sort by one
of them so after sorting say let's sort
by length then after this after sorting
I may get something like this right and
if I am asking what's the compatible set
of with this guy I still have to kick
all of them out
yeah so it's entirely not entirely clear
to me how to do it but I think you can
potentially consider having another say
binary tree that's sorted by width and
you can go in and just delete everything
larger than a certain width so that's
the yeah okay
okay okay but constructing that graph
already takes all 10 square correct
okay let's move on I don't have time to
figure this out no let's think about so
this problem is remotely similar to
interval scheduling weighted interval
scheduling right in in a sense that it
has some compatible set and in the very
first lecture and recitation we have two
algorithm for weighted interval
scheduling and one of them is better
than the other this one looks like the
naive algorithm so does anyone remember
what the better algorithm is for
weighted interval scheduling
instead of checking every one as my
potential lowest one it really doesn't
make sense to do that because for the
very small ones I shouldn't put it put
them as my bottom one I should only try
I should try the larger ones first
yep crap so just in the same line of
thought as weighted interval scheduling
let's first assault them but then his a
little tricky because do I sort by
length or width so I'm not sure yet but
so let's just sort by length and then
with so this means if they have the same
length than our sort them by with so I
can create a sorted list
let me just assume that it's a in place
sort and now I have the sorted list so
once I have that so I should the
question also the possible solutions I
should consider is that whether or not
or not I put my first block as the
bottom one right it doesn't make sense
for me to put those later ones down so
my subproblem i sorry if my original
problem becomes taking a max and whether
or not i choose block 1 if I do then I
get its weight a high story and my sub
problem is
the ones compatible with it
correct
if I do not choose it let my subproblem
is what and reverse step from - all the
way to it so why is this correct so I
claim this cover all that covers all the
cases like either h1 is chosen as the
first bottom one or it's not it's not
chosen at all it's impossible for h1 to
be somewhere in the middle right because
it has the longest largest length okay
so how many subproblems do I have
still n so there all of these compatible
set of L 1 W 1 now 2 W 2 but looks like
I do have some new sub problems right
these do not exist before however there
are only n of them right there just a
suffix of the entire set right so I
still have o of n subproblems under each
step I'm doing constant amount of work
there just two items so we found the
order in solution I'll be done is it
really
order n ok nope yeah I still have to
find all these seeds and first I
actually have have a source step right
that sort step is and login yeah then
again what if we do it naively then it's
again n square because I have to find
this compatible set each of them but if
there is analog in solution to find
these compatible sets then my final
runtime is n log N
make sense
any questions so far
okay so now we actually have a choice so
we can either go through another DP
example I do have another one but then
see one of the lecture suggested that it
seems that many people have some trouble
understanding yesterday's lecture on
universal hashing and perfect hashing so
we can also consider going through that
well of course the third option is to
just call it a day and so so let me just
take a poll how many people prefer we go
over the hash stuff okay how many people
prefer another DP example okay sorry
guys how many people just want to leave
it's fine okay great that's it okay so
so much for DP and we do have another
example we are releasing recitation
notes for those of you who are
interested you can take a look so well
you know you all know that we haven't go
into DP in my lectures yet so this is
really just a warm-up and to prepare you
to go to the more advanced PP concepts
and also DP will be covered in quiz 1
but the difficulty will be strictly
easier than the examples we cover here
okay
now let's review universal and perfect
hashing so it's not like I have a better
way to teach it on our advantage here is
that we have fewer people so you can ask
questions you have so let me start with
the motivating example so why do we care
about hash it's because we want to
create a hash table of say M it has m
things and we will receive input say K 0
K 1 all the way to can K n minus 1 and
keys and we'll create a hash function to
each of them to map them to one of the
bins and the hope is that if if n is
Theta M or in the other way and they see
the N then each pin should contain a
constant number of keys so to complete a
picture all the keys are drawn from a
universe that has size you and this you
is usually pretty large let's say it's
larger than M square it's larger mine
than the square of my hash table size
but let me first start with a negative
result so if my hash function is
deterministic then there always exists a
series of input that all map to the same
thing
we call that worst case
we don't we don't like the worst case
why because in that case the Hajj is not
doing anything we still have all of the
items in the same list
ah why is that why is that llama true
because by a very simple teaching whole
argument so imagine I insert all of the
keys in the universe into my hash table
I will never do that in practice it's
just a thought experiment so by a simple
pigeonhole argument if u is greater than
M square then at least something will
contain more than M elements right well
if it just so happens that my input
are these M keys then my hash will hash
all of them to the same thing make sense
so this is the problem we are trying to
solve we don't want this worst case and
did that say that if H is deterministic
we cannot avoid that right they always
exist the worst case so what's the
solution then the solution is to
randomize H
however I can't really randomize H I so
if H take some key if my hash function
maps a key into a certain being well the
next time I call this hash function it
better give the same thing right
otherwise I cannot find that item so H
needs to be deterministic so now our
only choice is to pick a random H make
sense every hash function is
deterministic but we will pick a random
one from a family of hash functions so
in some sense it is this is cheating why
because all I'm saying is I will not
choose a hash function beforehand our
wait for the user to insert inputs if I
have too many collisions I'll choose
another one if I have too many
collisions out with another one okay I
think I forgot to mention one thing
that's important so you may ask why
twerk here why do I care about that
worst case what's the chance of it's
happening in practice it's very low but
in algorithms we really don't we really
don't like making assumptions input why
because if you imagine you are running
or say a website web server well your
code has some hash table in it so if
your competitor or someone who hates you
wants to put you out of business
and if he knows your hash function he
can create a worst case input right that
will make your website like infinitely
slow so what we are saying here is I
don't tell him what my what hash
function I'll use I'll say I choose one
if he figures out the wrong input the
worst case input I'm going to change my
hash function
use another one okay make sense
now the definition of universal hash
function
is that if I pick a random H from my
universal hash function family the
probability that any key I map to the
same thing as any KJ should be less or
equal than one over m where m is my hash
table this is really the best you can
get if H function is really evenly
distributing things you should get this
property so we have seen one universal
hash function in the class I'll give
just I'll just go over the other example
which is a k plus P modulo P and then
modulo n so P is a prime number that is
greater than the universe size we will
see why this is a universal hash
function so to do that we just need to
analyze the collision probability so if
I have two key that k1 k1 and k2 then
map to the same beam that means they
must have this property right after
taking a mod M their difference should
be a multiple of M right because if this
is true after I taking the modulo M they
will map to the same B make sense now I
can quickly write it as a time's the
difference of the key equals a multiple
of M mod P
now k1 and k2 are not equal so they are
nonzero and in this group we are based
on some numbers degree we have an
inverse element for it so if if this
happens we'll call it a bad a how many
bad days do I have so that's a bad one
one of a will make this equation holds
with I equals one another a make the
equation holds by I with I equals two
but how many such is do I have at most
like because this equation can hold with
M 2 M 3 M all the way to P over m floor
M right this is the total number of
possible ways this equation can hold so
how many bad 8 the bad days do I have I
have P over m over the total number of
A's which is P minus 1 well yeah I
forgot to mention that so a is from 1 to
P minus 1
okay so I can always choose my pee to be
not a multiple of em if I do that this
floor so then P and P minus 1 do not
cross the boundary of multiple m right
then this is true and this is less than
1 over m so this is a universal hash
function family
so what's the randomness here the
randomness is is a our picker a to get
my one of my hash and if it doesn't work
now pick another day huh P is a prime
number I choose yeah be our B is I think
it's also a random number so yeah so
actually it's not needed but I think
there's some deep reason then they keep
it in the hash function I'm not sure why
now once we have that once we have
universal hash people also want perfect
hashing which means I want absolute
absolutely zero creation so how do I do
that let me first give a method one I'll
just use any universal hash function but
my choose I choose my m to be n square I
claim this is a perfect hash function
with certain probability why because I
want to calculate probability no
collision
it's yeah one minus probability I do
have a collision and I can use a Union
bound that's the probability that any
pair as a collision any pair of H x
equals H y how many pairs do I have yeah
n choose 2 which is this number right
and based on so if it's a universal hash
function then any collision any two
colliding the probability is 1 over m
right so I choose my M to be n square so
this one is larger than 1/2 so what I'm
saying so to get a perfect Hogg hash
function I'll just use the simplest way
I select the universal hash function
with M equals n square I have a
probability more than 1/2 to succeed or
if I don't succeed I'll choose another
one until I succeed
so this is a randomized algorithm and we
can make it a one-color up with them or
Las Vegas algorithm so I can either say
if I choose alpha log n times then
what's the chance that none of my choice
studies fights perfect hashing these
probability is my failure probability is
less than this
right
by each chance I have a half success
rate and I try this many times what's
the chances of all of them failing this
is one over N raised to alpha
right of course I can also say I'll keep
trying until I succeed then I have a
100% success rate
but my run time could potentially go
unbound it make sense okay
this sounds like a perfect solution the
only problem is that the space
complexity of this method is n square
because I choose my M hash table size to
the N square so this is the only thing
we don't want in this simple method
our final goal is to have a perfect hash
function that has space over then and
also run time are some polynomial Union
and failure probability arbitrarily
small and the idea there is this
two-level hashing so I choose a h1 first
to hash my keys into into beings and for
each pin say I get our 1 elements here
our two elements here so on so forth
I'll choose each of the pins to be a
second level perfect hashing so we can
use the method 1 to choose this small
one right if I choose M 1 which is the
hash table size of this guy to be l1
square then I know after our for login
trial this one should be a perfect
hashing right after after another half a
login trial I should resolve all the
conflicts in l2 to make it a perfect
hashing make sense so after n log n
trials I will make all of these I will
resolve all the conflicts in my second
level hashing questions
let me think about that offline I am not
sure about that
okay so the only remaining problem is we
need to figure out whether we achieve
this space of n what is the space
complexity of this algorithm is n plus
Li square because each table each table
size is the square of the elements in it
and finally we have that markov
inequality things something like that to
prove this is this is the case with so
my space is all then also with the
probability of greater than 1/2 then I
can keep going
I'll try our for log n times on my first
level hash function until my space is
all then right once I get get to that
point I'll try choosing universal hash
functions for my smaller tables until I
succeed ok
that's it for hashing and DBT
so it's mentioned that it's only study